[Music]
the inspiring life story of saitama the
man
called one punch man the concept of
heroes has always been there
and we've always been surrounded by it
heroes like superman and batman have
always been a part of our childhood
but if we're talking about anime then
there are not so many mainstream heroes
now are there
there are characters like luffy naruto
and goku
but these characters can't be labeled as
just heroes they've got their own
specific titles
be that as it may almost six years ago
back in 2015
this finally changed as the anime medium
introduced a hero
with the anime called one punch man the
name of this hero
saitama and as time passed by he went on
to compete with superman
and batman in terms of popularity it
isn't a stretch to say that our hero
cytomine is also the gateway for many
people who eventually get into anime
his powers don't involve superficial
things like lasers or tools
it's just a lot simpler than that with
strength that's enough to send waves
across the globe
legs that can make the trip all the way
from the moon back to the earth in a
split second
and speed that's practically
imperceivable he is
in every sense of the word invincible
and as they say
behind every great man there's an
equally great story
from the moment he vowed to become a
hero until the day he became strong
enough to defeat most and every kind of
enemy opponent with a single punch
and everything that happened in between
let's talk about it all
not many people know about this but
there's an extra chapter in volume 1 of
the one punch man manga
the chapter that goes by the name 200
yen it's the 8.5th chapter back when he
was a child
cythermic used to watch superhero shows
and he always dreamt of becoming a hero
on the second day of middle school when
he was just 12 years old he's in his
class reading a manual while the other
students talk about how two seniors
ridiculed a first-year student who was
just trying to protect some students
from getting bullied by them
what's interesting about this first-year
student was that he called himself
the bicycle commuter and he tried his
best to stand up against the bullies
because he was on the side of justice
what do you think was this boy the hero
that will soon be known as the legendary
moomin rider
share your thoughts in the comment
section below
now while this topic was going on in his
class cytoma
wasn't particularly interested in that
conversation he was just passing time by
reading whatever he was reading
later when he's home he's lying around
on his bed while the tv mentions how the
number of monsters have been surging for
the past few years
and how we need a system to ensure the
safety of the citizens
saitama was in thought be that as it may
he was also just lying around and
ignoring all the homework he had to do
the next day the homeroom teacher
lectures him on how important it is to
do your homework
he was listening but he didn't quite
understand why the teacher was so
assertive about it
he ended up talking back which got him
into a little bit of trouble
the teacher told him to meet him after
school which obviously he didn't like
cythermic had a very serious look on his
face as he returned to his seat
later school ends and he's on his way to
meet the teacher but those two bullies
stop him and ask for money
he tells them he doesn't have any
embraces himself to fight
he acted like the man he was though for
the 12 year old saitama
these bullies were too much they beat
him up and they take the 200 yen that he
had in his pocket
for context 200 yen amounts to roughly a
couple of dollars
that's why the bullies ridiculed him
even more because of the good for
nothing that he was
but then as he's getting mocked a
monster enters the chat
he bumps in to sign them unlike a bull
the two bullies are terrified
but the monster just takes the money and
leaves now this didn't sit right with
saith them at all
he was tired of being weak all those
dreams he had of being a hero
were they all just delusions was he
fated to be weak for the rest of his
life
something inside of side them are
triggers he runs after the monster
desperately trying to get his 200 yen
back
it wasn't that he didn't want to lose
his 200 yen it wasn't that it was more
like he didn't want to just sit by as
someone
or something took his money he didn't
want to be weak
he changed the monster for a while but
at one point the monster just turned and
bumped right into him
saitama was out for an hour when he woke
up the monster was already dealt with
in the end he never got his 200 yen back
and the teacher lectured him
once again more so than before and then
as he's on his way back home
saitama's mind is full of thoughts his
monologue clearly represented the
current state of his existence
he says that he might not be fit to live
in this society he doesn't have the
faintest idea of how to live in this
world
all he ever does is lose will he ever be
able to live his life properly when he's
this weak
these were the thoughts that lurked
around in the mind of the 12 year old
saitama
fast forward 10 years later we see a bit
of the day saitama became a hero for the
first time
this flashback is shown in the very
first episode
saitama is a 22 year old unemployed man
he's hunting for a job but with no luck
all he's doing is working part-time at a
convenience store but then one day after
coming back from another failed
interview
he encounters a monster called crablante
however when the crab sees the look
inside them as eyes
he decides to spare him maybe it's
because the crab
somehow related to saitama's lifeless
eyes so he spares him and goes back to
find the boy with a cleft like a chin
cytoma doesn't think much of it but he
does see the child before the crab
and a few moments later the crabs also
there
now as the man who once saw out to be a
hero as the person who was sick of being
so weak all the time
saitama's faced with a number of
dilemmas the situation isn't as grave as
it seems to be actually
in fact the reason the crab wants the
kid dead is because he drew something on
him with a permanent marker
but that didn't change the fact that he
legit wanted to kill the boy
as this plays out something inside of
cytoma triggers once again
just like it did 10 years ago only this
time he
actually finds a way he literally pulls
out the crab's eyeball with just his tie
and renders the crab useless that day
the boy said them i saved was the
grandson of a wealthy man
and hearing the story makes the man
decide to create the hero association
but neither the world nor the other
heroes not even cite them i himself
knows that it was him who became the
foundation of the world's strongest
association
however starting that day cythma decided
he's not just suited for a normal life
he swore to become strong and as we saw
in the third episode of the first season
every day he did 100 push-ups 100
sit-ups
100 squats and a 10 kilometer run in
summer he didn't turn on the air
conditioner and in winter he didn't turn
on the heat
he survived on bananas he made himself
uncomfortable
and gradually he started to feel some
change
as it's mentioned in the manga on the
300th day of his training he'd already
become aware of the fact that he'd
become strong
then there was a strong monster who was
looking for a strong opponent
saitama was in the middle of his run and
yet for the very first time in forever
zytoma destroyed a monster with a single
punch
by this point saithemart was already
superhuman
after one and a half years of his
training he'd become bold
but let's not forget that he'd become
strong too obviously fans have wondered
how he became so strong with just a
standard level training manual
it's been explained that through the
training in his will saitama was able to
completely remove the limiter that
exists in humans
unlike other people who become stronger
and stronger by expanding their limiter
he completely removed it and became
strength itself
it's such a shame that he's yet to
receive the proper amount of respect in
the actual story
but as far as us fans are concerned
saitama's the world's strongest hero
[Music]
largely
there you go that was seitan's story his
beginning and how he became the
strongest
i'm sure you have a lot to say about
this so feel free to share your thoughts
in the comment section down below
you